Now that we have a handle on what
constructor functions are and
how they're created,
let's dive in to underscore source code.
Keep in mind the things
we've been discussing so
far about template delimiters.
Don't get bogged down in the nitty
gritty details of the function, but
focus on what is happening to
the template string that's passed in.
Let's do this.
I've got the developer tools
open to the source tab and
I’ve open the projects at file.
When this line is run, remember that it
converts the template to a string and
passes it to underscores
template function.
This function is defined
in underscore on line 1415.
As a tip, you can press control g and
type in the line number.
Now, let's set a break
point on this first line.
Refreshing the page with command or
control r will pause execution right as
it's starting to build up the template.
We can see that we got to this line
from f j.s by checking the call stack.
Remember that the text variable holds
the contents of the html template.
Chrome will show us what a variable
holds if we now mouse over the variable.
If you're feeling adventurous,
how about you pause the video, and
see if you can step
through the code yourself.
If you get stumped, or even if you make
it all the way through to the end,
come back, and
we can go through it together.
These lines here determine what
delimiters to look for in the template.
If you want to override
the default delimiters,
you can pass them in as part
of the settings argument.
This matcher variable is
the set of delimiters.
Since we didn't override them,
they're the ones we looked at already.
Matcher is a regular expression.
Regular expressions are out of
the scope of this course, but
it would be helpful to know the basics.
You'll find some resources on regular
expressions in the instructor notes.
These buttons over here let
us step through the code.
And I'll use them as we
move through everything.
This line starts the new source string.
The rest of the function
will add to this string.
This is what will become the body
of the constructor function.
These lines here take the text and
replaces it with the contents
of the matched delimiter.
Let's step through one
loop to see how it works.
Replace user's maitre which if you
remember is a regular expression.
To search for a starting and
ending delimiter pair.
The first one it found
is stored in match.
The delimiters that were found in
this match were the interpolate ones.
Looking at the current scope,
the match's content is stored
in the interpolate variable.
If the contents were stored
in the escape variable,
then that variable would
get saved to a T variable.
Which gets wrapped in
underscore's escape function and
is added to the source string.
If the contents were stored
in the escape variable
then that variable will get saved to
a T variable which gets wrapped in
underscore's escape function and
is added to the source string.
If the contents were
stored in Interpolate,
then it gets directly added
to the source string.
If the contents are stored in evaluate,
then it gets directly added
to the source string.
Interpolate and
evaluate are similar, but
interpolate will insert the contents.
While evaluate will
actually run the code.
The replace function loops through
the entire text string until it finds
all the delimiters and adds their
contents to the source string.
The next few lines add a little bit
more to the front of the source string.
We've been using the t and
p variables already.
This is where they are created.
All of the hard work of building up
the source string is finally about
to pay off.
A new function is created with
the source string as the last argument.
Remember that the last argument to a
constructor function becomes the body of
that function.
This new function is stored in render.
Now this render function, and this
template function are very important.
Template will be called at
some later point with data.
When template is called it calls render
and passes along the data it receives.
Believe it or not, that's the end.
Underscore adds a source property to
the function, which we used earlier, and
then it returns the template function.